my lords
and members of the house of commons
i am deeply grateful
for the addresses of condolence
by the house of lords and the house of
commons
which so touchingly encompass
what our late sovereign
my beloved mother the queen
meant to us all
as shakespeare says of the earlier queen
elizabeth
she was
a pattern to all princes living
as i stand before you today
i cannot help but feel the weight
of history which surrounds us
and which reminds us
of the vital parliamentary traditions
to which members of both houses
dedicate yourselves
with such personal commitment
for the betterment of us all
parliament
is the living and breathing instrument
of our democracy
that your traditions
are ancient
we see
in the construction of this great hall
and the reminders of medieval
predecessors
of the office
to which i have been called
and the tangible connections
to my darling late mother
we see
all around us
from the fountain in new palace yard
which commemorates the late
queen silver jubilee
to the sundial
in old palace yard
for the golden jubilee
the magnificent stained glass
window before me
for the diamond jubilee
and so poignantly
and yet to be formally unveiled
your most generous gift to her late
majesty
to mark
the unprecedented platinum jubilee
which we celebrated
only three months ago
with such joyful hearts
the great bell
of big ben
one of the most powerful
symbols of our nation
throughout the world
and housed within the elizabeth tower
also named for my mother's diamond
jubilee
will mark the passage
of the late queen's progress
from buckingham palace
to this parliament
on on wednesday
my lords
and members of the house of commons
we gather today
in remembrance
of the remarkable span of the queen's
dedicated service
to her nations and peoples
while very young
her late majesty
pledged herself to serve her country
and her people
and to maintain the precious principles
of constitutional government
which lie at the heart
of our nation
this vow she kept
with unsurpassed devotion
she set an example
of selfless duty
which
with god's help
and your counsels
i am resolved faithfully to follow